es gibt einen neuen stand was das
verhältnis von alpa gun und bushido
angeht darüber berichtete alpa gun jetzt
im community video und mich würde
interessieren wie findet ihr unsere neue
art nutzerfragen dran kommen zu lassen
und auf kommentare einzugehen das bitte
unter diesem video kommentieren
ansonsten ist ein patt ab
xp
nix mtx oder so ähnlich fragt stimmt es
dass du nur eine halbe stunde gemeint
hast als fahrer dich gelöst hat
ich habe eineinhalb stunden gelacht weil
es so witzig so
witzig wagen ein haar auf dem kopf wie
ein hubschrauberlandeplatz ist nicht
heilbar warum bist du sailer
war kein auftritt aber ich es war ein
riesengroßes erlebnis für mich es war
für mich eine ehre
eine allianz arena zu sein und unseren
bruder jerome boateng haben wir
unterstützt life to live wir haben 2 1
gegen madrid gewonnen ja mit trisomie
meinhof mein bruder herz wir waren im
stadion und und weiß was für eine karte
ich hatte nein eine ehrenkarte ja also
die karten kosten 1500 euro muss man
sich erst mal den rest aber ich weiß wir
haben nicht in die taschen gegriffen wir
sind familie auf jeden fall haben die
geworden und das erste mal habe ich im
stadion richtig gejubelt und mein bruder
andy jubelt jérôme boateng haben über 21
madrid hause ich wollte dich fragen wie
kommt es eigentlich dazu wie kam es dazu
dass du angefangen hast zu retten das
möchte ich mal gerne wissen vielleicht
wollen dass auch andere wissen
wie ich angefangen habe ich habe ich kam
halt dazu durchklicken das würde ich
natürlich nicht raten bloß die pfoten
weg davon
ich habe viel zu erzählen ich habe die
richtigen leute getroffen und
habe angefangen zu rappen weil ich viel
zu erzählen hat von der straße mein
talent habe ich auch spät entdeckt aber
ich habe es geschafft entdeckt und bin
froh dass ich heute euch da draußen
erzählt kann visier und auf der straße
abgekommen
fragen bitte welcher rapper abgesehen
von dir selbst ist der beste in
deutschland objektiv gesehen denn
eigentlich müsste er da kollegah sagen
überhaupt nicht der beste rapper für
mich in deutschland /
sr ist ein rapper fans des rsl rapper
der beste der besten
cyber xc 13 fragt alba kannst du bushido
leiden und wie war es früher mit ihm das
ist echt die beste frage ich meine alle
deine frage sind gut aber das war die
beste heute ja ich kann konnte bushido
heute nicht leiten wir haben halt eine
negative vergangenheit wie channel zeigt
auch nicht so gut auf jeden fall haben
wir uns letzte woche zufällig getroffen
ich bin mit einer reizenden dame aus
gehören wollen essen gehen dann habe ich
ihn sein label chef und sein werk neuen
backup rapper im restaurant getroffen im
selben laden wo ich essen gehen wollte
mit der reizenden dame und bushidos
echten mann zu mir gekommen und hat sich
bei mir entschuldigt wegen der
vergangenheit und weil er so gerade und
ehrlich gemacht hat möchte ich natürlich
auch wer ein mann entgegen gekommen wir
haben kein böses blut diese ganze reihe
haben wir jetzt aus der welt geschaffen
ja da hat sich aber ihn entschuldigt ich
hab ja nichts zu entschuldigen sag ich
nicht gelesen und beantwortet
okay das ist keine dieser nummer das
heißt kein wissen ich habe geantwortet
okay ich habe mich auch entschuldigt ist
natürlich für alle das was passiert ist
wir haben uns gegenseitig entschuldigt
ich habe gemerkt der junge
ist ruhiger geworden er nimmt sein leben
jetzt ernsthaft er will kein liefen kein
stress haben er kriegt auch ein kind im
juli ich wünsche ihnen alles gute viel
gesundheit für sein kind reststoffe
kommt gesund und munter auf die welt
auf jeden fall kein böses blut ich meine
wir sind jetzt auch keine besten freunde
oder kumpels aber wir sind jetzt gut
miteinander also das heißt nicht dass
gleich mit ihnen jetzt auch ein carlo
cokxxx [__] drei album machen muss 23
auf jeden fall wünsche ich dir alles
gute musik mit deinem kind viel erfolg
in der zukunft mein respekt alles gute
aber jetzt muss ich noch mal ganz dumm
fragen sido hat sich mit bushido
vertragen du hast dich bushido vertragen
warum können dann alpa gun und sido
nicht vertragen das ist jetzt gerade
frisch okay das muss jetzt erst mal
laufen
und machen das ist ganz anders kann man
das könnte ich auch sagen da ist der
bushido ist gekommen naja ok muss jedes
wie ein mann gekommen und hat sich
entschuldigt aber sie du wo ist nur wo
es sie doch seine ehre dass er zu mir
kommt wie ein junger mann befreundet wo
bist du kommen wie regen war alles
besser wenn er mir dieses lied wenn er
nicht auf mich zukommen diesen schritt
auf mich zu machen ich komme auf gar
keinen fall auch ein schritt auf ihn zu
ich habe jahrelang war ich finde da wenn
es schon so wenn euch dieses community
video gefallen hat dann wird euch sicher
auch die nutzer frage an farid bang
gefallen bei der erklärt dass er sie
bloß karriere beenden wird was ihm aber
bisher wohl noch nicht so ganz gelungen
ist oder auch werden ja gerade mit alpa
gramm über seinen lieblings rapper
gesprochen die frage an bushido nach
seinem lieblingssong von seinen eigenen
falls auch das interessiert klickt da
drauf und ansonsten bis dankbar